all's I remember is waking up and just
saying I need help that's all I knew is
something bad happened and I needed help
former bachelor Chris soules is speaking
out about his fatal 2017 car accident in
a new interview with Good Morning
America the 37 year old opened up about
his decision to leave the site of the
accident a decision that led to two
years probation for Chris I was charged
with leaving the scene of a serious
injury accident a man did die and and
that's it was a tragedy my sentence is
living with this rest of my life
66 year-old Iowa farmer Kenneth Mosher
died as a result of the crash I was
driving down a rural road a country road
in the dark and and the next thing I
know I'm I'm basically coming to inside
of one of our pickups after calling 911
ministering CPR and waiting for the
paramedics to arrive Chris left the
scene and returned to his house though
he insists he had quote nothing to hide
I don't know that I was thinking clearly
I notified the authorities of what had
happened
the paramedics were there but I know I
just know was scared and wanted to be in
a safer place I just went home when I
left I called my parents you know
they're both in consensus to said call
an attorney chris was later arrested and
initially pleaded not guilty to the
charges a police report cited alcoholic
containers in the car at the time of the
crash but Chris adamantly denies that he
was drinking I mean the fact is the
truck is not mine it's not even in my
name we employ over 15 people and those
cans could have been anybody's there
were four witnesses that swore under
oath that they they saw no evidence of
Meece appearing to be intoxicated or
under the influence of any sort of drug
or alcohol and while chris says he did
everything in his power to save
Kenneth's life after the accident he
wishes he could have done more I wish I
could have saved his life I wish I
wouldn't have been on that road
I just hope you know I did everything I
could
this is truly such a sad story and our
hearts go out to everyone involved until
next time I'm Hallie Stevens bye for now
[Music]